أكدت الإمارات العربية المتحدة أن
ثلاثة مدنيين قتلوا
مواطنًا باكستانيًا وهنديين عندما
تم شن هجوم بطائرة بدون طيار في
منشأة النفط الضخمة هذه خلفي ، على
ما يبدو ، يقولون إن نوعًا من
خزان تخزين النفط قد أصيب مما تسبب في رد فعل متسلسل للقطار
أدى إلى
أدى انفجار ناقلة بترول إلى مقتل هؤلاء
الأفراد وإصابة ستة آخرين ، كما
وقع هجوم آخر بطائرة بدون طيار على منطقة
قيد الإنشاء في مطار أبو ظبي الدولي الجديد ،
ولم يسفر عن
أي إصابات ، ولكن في كلتا الحالتين
يقول المسؤولون الإماراتيون إن نوعًا من
الطائرات بدون طيار كان  شوهد
في الجو فوق بالطبع
القوات الجوية الإماراتية لديها الآن طائرات مقاتلة أه في
السماء يقولون إنهم
سيطروا على الحرائق وهذا كله
قادم لأن الحوثيين يعلنون
مسؤوليتهم عما يقولون إنه
هذا الهجوم بعيد المدى  إذا
تم تنفيذ هجوم بطائرة بدون طيار من اليمن
بعيد المدى للغاية ،
لكنهم حصلوا على شكل
لإجراء ر  هذه الأنواع من الهجمات ،
لا سيما في المملكة العربية السعودية الآن في
الأشهر القليلة الماضية ،
اتهم الحوثيون الإمارات
بالدعم المتزايد لبعض الميليشيات على
الأرض التي تقاتلهم كجزء من
تلك الحرب الأهلية التي أعقبت
الانسحاب الرسمي لقوات حركة المقاومة الإسلامية من اليمن.  مرة أخرى في
عام 2020 ويقوض جهود الإمارات
لمحاولة
إعادة ضبط سياستها الخارجية
الدولية لتصبح صديقًا للجميع
وعدوًا
لأحدهم سام كيلي
أبو ظبي